[Music]
welcome back to CBS mornings where we
are taking another look at the historic
settlement between Dominion voting
systems and Fox News accused of
defamation for knowingly airing false
claims phony claims really that Dominion
helped rig the 2020 election against
former president Donald Trump the voting
machine company asked for 1.6 billion
dollars in Damages what fox agreed to in
the end was to pay a little less than
half of that
787 and a half million the news company
put out a statement to quote acknowledge
the Court's rulings finding certain
claims about Dominion to be false Fox
did not apologize and three prime time
hosts Who aired those false claims did
not mention the settlement on their air
last evening joining us now is DaVita
Brook one of Dominion's lead attorneys
in this case Miss Brook thank you very
much for being here a lot of people
paying attention to this case a lot of
people paying attention to this
settlement I'd love for you if you could
just take us into the room yesterday the
judge is ready the jury is ready and
then at the last moment you strike this
deal what was the mood like as you're at
the table with Fox's lawyers on the
other side
thank you good morning you know it was
bittersweet for Dominion in the sense
that I think like so many of us we were
all excited to go to trial and to
continue in our efforts to expose so
much of what we've already been able to
expose over the course of this
litigation but what yesterday really
brought for my client demitting voting
systems is it brought peace and so with
the settlement the good people of
dominion are now able to try to begin to
move on with their lives a little bit
why was it enough for you to take the
money which is substantial don't get me
wrong but no apology why did you agree
to a deal that does not include an
on-air acknowledgment and an apology
from this company that has done you such
harm over the last uh three years
defamation law gets you two things it
gets you accountability and it gets you
justice and we feel like we got both
those things in Spade like I said over
the past two and a half years we've been
able to expose everything that fox knew
when it broadcast these horrific lies
about my company the country now knows
that the world now knows that and with
the summary judgment ruling we got from
this great Court we now have a decision
that those lies were clearly just that
the other thing we needed was Justice
and you know how a company like Fox
apologizes it apologizes with money and
787 million dollars we figured spoke
volumes
but miss Brook if if I work in the sales
department of dominion voting and I'm
dealing with a county looking to buy my
machines and that County's got a lot of
conservative Fox viewers who don't
believe Dominion is a legit company that
believes Dominion is switching votes or
against Donald Trump you don't have
anything on paper correct me if I'm
wrong from Fox Corporation saying
actually Dominion is a fine and
legitimate company and we are sorry for
what we said earlier
we have a statement from Fox News
finally finally after so long
acknowledging the Court's ruling and
that the statements were false and I can
tell you that the information that we're
getting from the election officials is
just wonderful they are incredibly
grateful for the fight that we put up
for the lies that we exposed and for the
justice that we were able to get really
not just for Dominion but for them
because they too have spent the last two
and a half years facing harassment
facing threats and facing all of these
types of things that no one should ever
have to face simply for doing their job
yeah what's the sticking point in the
end the apology or the dollar amount
for us again it was about accountability
and it was about Justice the kids at Fox
they're big boys and girls if they want
to say something more they can and they
should
we'll see if we hear more from the big
boys and girls as you put it there is
another lawsuits Mark Matt smartmatic
voting company our voting systems an
even larger dollar amount that they're
asking for will you be sharing have you
already begun to share information with
their attorneys
so I am not coordinating with the
attorneys for smartmatic that said my
client Dominion voting system does have
several other cases that it is pursuing
in the aftermath of the 2020
presidential elections and the lies that
it was spread about it including one
right here in this Courthouse behind me
in front of the same judge who oversaw
the Fox News case against this one is
against Newsmax we also have lawsuits
pending against one America news as well
as various individuals in the District
of Columbia
and we look forward to moving on to
those cases Miss Brook just one final
question before I let you go for those
people who were rooting for a trial who
are not going to get one now who think
this was great for Dominion great for
its investors maybe great for its
employees as well but bad for democracy
bad for America what do you say to that
viewer in particular
I say to that viewer the
settled when we when we did we didn't
set
and so we didn't settle before the
information was able to become public
you now know we all now know Fox new and
we are grateful that that happened first
all right DaVita Brooks 787 and a half
can't forget the half million dollar
settlement with Fox Corporation thank
you very much for your time this morning
thank you